it is time for drew's news
pop your news hood and we'll top off
that good news oil
and with me at the desk my trusty
co-pilot ross matthews hi everybody hi
holly
i am honored to introduce incredible
actors writers comedians and together
they host the mega hit podcast [ __ ]
sesh please welcome the ones the onlys
casey wilson and danielle schneider
you and i over the last few years have
made friends
i was lucky enough to have you and jun
come on early in the show um
then casey came back on the show and i
got to do her makeup which was really
fun i got right in your focus i know i
need you today i mean you know you made
me look there i am gorgeous yeah that's
us being intimate girls cute
and bonding yep
and we geeked out about the netflix
series called you
because we were obviously
somehow drawn to penn badgley and his
obsessive behavior and kind of wondering
why there weren't men obsessing about us
the same way no why is no one putting me
in a basement and trying to kill me it's
so unacceptable
but we had such a blast together and and
then i went back to my podcast i have to
tell the story to kind of tell danielle
all about what had happened here and
meeting you
and we had we did have a little bit of a
mix-up we had a threes company classic
yeah mix them up seas
and we had talked about i said that you
told danielle that uh that i loved well
how do we put it he said um well here
actually look at this it's it's it'll
help this is what happened
i i was had the good fortune of doing
drew barrymore but i had so much fun we
both discussed our love of you and penn
baggage totally
oh i thought for just a second casey
oh god this is so embarrassing when you
said we both discussed our love of you i
thought
drew barrymore knew who i was and loved
me
unfortunately i meant the number one
show on netflix
oh it wasn't
it wasn't you
it was the show you know danielle
thought casey said that we were talking
about you danielle and that we loved you
danielle yeah and it was a you not you
mix-up and danielle was was crying i was
crying because drew is such an icon to
me and i feel like we've grown up
together and so to hear she loved me i
was like oh my god and then i was like
oh gosh this is so embarrassing because
she doesn't know who i am oh well it was
kind of hard but i but you then reached
out because you said i have to make it
up to danielle and i myself felt
terribly again she was in full blown
explosive tears both thinking that you
loved her and then finding out you did
not actually know her i'm not well yeah
and so it was so upsetting and so you
came and surprised us yeah on on on your
[ __ ] sesh like amazing my
and our podcast is about their
housewives and you showed up in emeritus
mark's chain link face mask as one does
everyone died yes and it was such a huge
moment for me and i was so excited and i
was like oh my god i now know drew loves
me not you but me yeah
[Music]
i might lock you up in a basement i'll
be in your basement any day drew
[Music]